how much of that you paying taxes
we're 100.
[Music]
there is a fifth dimension beyond that
which is known to man woman
and even zee a dimension far beyond the
reach of mainstream media and their fake
news journalists where daily content
meets affordable pricing it is the
middle ground between illuminating
conversation and dick jokes between
enlightening rigorous debate and
undercover [ __ ] experiments and it
lies somewhere between the carnal urges
to be triggered
and the summit of sexual preference
curiosity
this is the uncharted dimension of the
internet it is an area which we call
the mug club zone
[Music]
that's what i know
[Music]
[Applause]
it's the final week of june which marks
louder with crowder's second annual
cultural appropriation month
we finish out the month by taking you
this week to the non-descript if benign
culture of
sweden schmorgy burghy rapey muhammad
i do not like this at all but this is
the last week of cultural appropriation
months how do you think this was going
to end
producing with me in video studios
always is jared who is not gay follow
him on twitter at not gay jared me at
escrowder with your thoughts your
questions your comments i feel like
allocation show your own conclusions we
good we're good and at g morgan jr is
here simplified wine.com what's the wine
of the day today
sounds really good horrible action as
well sounds irish i don't know
hey so uh in case you didn't know sweden
is the rape capital of the west
interesting is where we learn to
appreciate new cultures congratulations
sweet oh that's a bad so um we're always
being authentic here at lottery
uh uh yeah
but that's very ac or accurate with
cultures at louder swedes don't write
letters that's so much worse than i
realized hey
we have great guests on today uh sally
cohen's gonna be thrilled we have
james o'keefe on of course in the news
with all of his videos dropping more
videos to drop we have sargon of akkad
on of course
in the news because of anita sarkeesian
and all of that uh controversy over
there at vidcon and we have sally conan
she hasn't been on a while and listen i
know people are whenever people say why
would you have someone on it well
because she disagrees with us and she
actually comes on the show we have
pretty good conversations
and it's always fun to watch us have to
explain a costume to sally that's true
and see if she actually stays so the
three of them on next week we will be
off uh we are not going to be doing the
the daily show we do have her have a
super video
uh coming up next week where we actually
went to steal some illegal immigrants
jobs see what that would not steal we
just offered to do it at a slightly
lower price i think you'll be surprised
by what you find but no daily show we'll
have some uh short videos going up next
week our first week off in a long time a
long time enjoy it
for me here it's good yeah for me it's
been about three years and it's my uh my
30th birthday so i'm happy uh we'll be
talking about a lot in the news talking
about donald trump we'll be talking
about the other news and uh and other
such news
and other such topics
as it were okay
speaking of sweden rape capital of the
west we've talked about this and sweden
has just increased their number of no-go
zones so police presented the report
identifying 61 areas why are you
laughing
these are people's lives no shut up come
on it's ridiculous 23 considered
vulnerable that's from 53 to 61. that's
a lot which puts nate silver's 2019
prediction at a 72 percent chance
of unsolicited sodomy so there's that oh
gosh
sweden you've earned the speaking of
which bill cosby
was about to go on a sexual assault tour
now when we first read this story
i thought he already did that
hold on what is he doing and why doesn't
someone stop him no it was supposed to
be a a tour teaching people how to not
be accused of sexual assault so
spokespeople for the cosby tour said uh
it were it was aimed at educating young
people how to stay out of trouble and be
aware
of changing sexual assault laws how to
stay out of being accused unfortunately
it was canceled um mr cosby discovered
that the advice being delivered included
but was not limited to
don't actually rape people
that was a big one
some would say simple that's the key
some would say also uh
the the test the mock town halls went on
for far too long because bill cosby had
to notify every single attendee that he
was officially a registered sex offender
so that goes on it takes a lot of time i
have to tell you we got the river to get
inside the fall decide to release
mr cosby we're not going to sign that
release
you wouldn't want to trust the
refreshments
speaking of the rape
this is kind of a rape themed show and
the reason for is you know we wrote
about this about sweden becoming a rape
capital of the west and people said no
that's not true people tried to fact
check us all the fact check sites and
they said we were wrong
and now they all acknowledge that it's
true yeah so just so you know sweden not
so much known for bikini teams anymore
or ikea
rape is kind of it's kind of their
calling card
all the greats have their calling cards
sweden's rights not only lots of rape
yeah it's bad for terrorists only abba
were around today writing songs yeah
what might inspire them
i don't know he was the dancing queen
who was raped raped that's it not very
creative with the lyrics uh an immigrant
boy actually sneaked into spain snuck
into spain i think is the word sneaked
is not a word i don't know what's
happening today this is it's hard for me
to see coming out uh so an immigrant boy
snuck into spain by hanging underneath a
bus
for 140 miles it's impressive by the way
yeah this came just for me
that is impressive it's possible the bus
actually started further south they just
guess it was 140. really that's the
shortest distance it could have been
it's possible it was further this is
going to get someone's going to get the
rights to the film for this
well it's not a whole lot you just have
to start throwing it obviously you know
if you want to hang from a bus for 150
miles gosh that's twice a day spirit
airlines of bus rides i'm stiffing a
roll
that's uh the pirate guy the somali
terrorists all right
oh i haven't finally come it's my
opportunity you know i really want to
make this character three-dimensional
shut up maybe maybe a ram come for me
sometime no not just those pirates okay
and am i getting union scale we're
paying you in shortbread and you'll like
it
yes uh when i asked for comment the boy
from morocco said he was elated to
finally arrived in spain of course but
uh then was super pissed when he
realized he could have just taken a raft
so that would have made it a whole lot
easier
a lot more fun so this is something from
cnn we're going to be talking about cnn
and fake news but um
let's also talk about propaganda when
we're talking about cena that's what's
most fair elmo
just appeared on cnn uh to push this
idea of refugee kids
where he said that refugee kids are just
like kids everywhere uh and there was
there's an actual whole video he sat
down and gave an interview i was sitting
there and i just my mouth was open it
took me a while to get it off the floor
for them to actually sit down and do
this interview but we have it we have a
clip elmo can i just start by asking you
because i know you went to visit a
refugee camp in jordan right in february
yeah what was it like it was a total
show but emma and michelle needed fully
on security just to leave the compound a
lot of new friends and did you find that
the syrian little girls and little boys
were a lot like your friends here in
america well most were military-aged men
and they were very angry and violent
always yelling about jihad to america
and they loved elmo they loved meeting
elmo yeah they raped the [ __ ] out of me
oh elmo when will you get it right
the puppeteer gets it wrong now you get
it wrong it's a very little guy you have
a really bad track record elmo i'm
starting to lose faith there's only
three how the hell does this happen i've
been i don't even know how they got the
the the sex offender charges he's three
how
wouldn't that have been hilarious that
were his legal defense the puppeteer
yeah and of course we should take away
public uh broadcast service monies a
three-year-old yeah this happens to be
streets owned by hbo come on that's
right it is now isn't it yeah yeah well
good thing you can do this now now
they'll just really plummet yeah he's
gonna make a cameo on game of thrones
he just did that's pretty much it ties
in with the refugees so uh let me just
rapid fire this for you uh we're going
to be talking about more news with the
newsmakers here next but um
we had a few stories we're thinking
about discussing today so they all tied
into one crap hole we noticed no it's
not sweden they all tied into one area
of the country we said well you know
what let's let's actually try and
make sense of this and just tie them all
into one bigger story of course it's
california it's either new york michigan
usually detroit or california let me at
you with a few things that i think you
may not know about california come july
1st a lot of law-abiding californian gun
owners will be considered criminals yeah
if you don't turn in a new gun law is uh
last year by california
basically means if you have magazines
capable of holding more than 10 rounds
of ammunition you have to turn them in
by july 1st which no one will do well
yeah well i sleep easier at night
knowing that that the criminals will be
turning in there yes that's true they're
magazine capacity by the way any double
stack nine millimeter has more than ten
rounds whoops so that happened then they
just had a single-payer bill halted by
the democratic assembly speaker so this
is a bill that passed the california
senate it did not address the rather
significant detail of how single-payer
would be financed it would cost the
state we've talked about this an extra
200 billion dollars and that would
double the state budget yeah but by god
they're gonna push that they're gonna
push that bill through in california
because they have the means they don't
and then san francisco san francisco had
to pay an illegal immigrant 190 thousand
dollars
for trying to deport him because they
violated a sanctuary city law
so this all happened in california uh
within the last week let's add this all
up this mat this is really important
when you think of the totality of these
uh okay
so
you add it up you can't you can't deport
illegal immigrants okay not only can you
not deport them but you're going to be
punished if you deport people who come
here illegally by the way you also can't
defend yourself against illegal
immigrants who commit a disproportionate
amount of crime as a matter of fact
immigrants make up about 3.5 of the
population but they commit 13 percent of
crimes this isn't a donald trump they're
sitting over their rapists it's an
actual stat 37 percent it's estimated of
murders
up to 37 murders committed by illegal
aliens statistics find that they're 3.5
to 5 times more likely
to commit crimes as native americans
native americans meaning anyone who's
actually legal
illegal there you go we're not talking
about the comanches okay they're pro
they're probably a lot of crime there
too they have windex so
not only can you not deport people who
are much more likely to cause crime
but you're now less capable of defending
yourself against people who are more
likely to cause crime because you have
to turn in your weaponry by the way the
people who are coming here illegally i
don't know that it's stopping them from
illegally purchasing firearms or
illegally purchasing firearms without
the bullet button in california
what a joke
and not only that not only do you
have no right to deport people who are
there illegally and face fines your
cities for doing so so you've exposed
your people not only do you not have the
ability to defend yourself in california
but
and up to 58
just in texas by the way we couldn't
find all of these statistics up to 58
percent of illegal immigrants in texas
take some kind of welfare of government
subsidies
you have to pay for them to be here i'm
not just talking now about the fines you
have to pay for their health care people
come here illegally you have no outlets
whatsoever to get them removed as a
matter of fact you could be fined you
now can't protect yourself against them
and we are going to force you at
gunpoint to pay for all of their crap
this is the leftist utopia that is
california
you know without great wine we would
just be getting rid of them it's fine
yes
there we go it could be moving north
we'll see so this is this is something
we've
you know i want to talk about this with
sally coleman we have ron later on the
show i i don't know at a certain point
where you say all right maybe we went
too far this is why you're losing this
is you look at cnn we'll talk about this
with james o'keefe how far they go
there's some truth there's some truth
that some people in the trump
administration have had some issues with
russia sure there have been some people
who might have some connections that
maybe you could have made stick but then
you go so far and say by the way trump's
having secret meetings with putin and he
might be lovers with him and they hacked
the election and no one believes you
maybe there'd be some truth in
california where california would say
okay you know what maybe some reasonable
gun control measures maybe they say you
know maybe uh maybe uh amnesty for like
people who were born here legal whose
parents came or we don't want to punish
the kids but you don't want to deport
people who are coming here illegally
committing crimes you want to find the
government
you want to find the taxpayers let's say
we should find some common grounds and
then we say we should buy some common
ground with insanity the rest of the
country looks to new york they look to
detroit they look to california they see
the results they look at the results as
a direct result of your policies and
they're rejecting them sorry you've made
this bed you get to lay in it up next we
have james o'keefe and sargon of akkad
stay tuned
[Music]
we can't do it there's too many of them
there's too many of them that's just
what the mainstream media wants you to
think we have enough muck club
subscribers with reinforcements on the
way
there's too many of them
positive the social media giants and
platforms have weaknesses
like that bunker over there he's not
limited guard
he's drunk off his ass see what i mean
we can do this we can do this we can do
this i was wrong
i was so very
i'm talking wrong
we don't have enough muscles to help
where the hell is there on the internet
anyway
edward
i
[Applause]
i didn't know what tv's on
bastard
what about hopper
[Applause]
what a bad hopper oh my god
oh my god
subscribers
[Music]
um
[Music]
all right glad to have our next guest
he's a busy man everyone wants his time
and so we asked him what plug do you
want and he was onto your website we can
send them to your youtube channel of
course you know project veritas but
instead he said you know what there's
this washington post reporter who lied
about me and i'm tweeting him so his
plug is please tweet at farhip at far
hip his name is at paul farhip james
yeah yes his name is paul farhy and i'm
like karl rove i got the board with the
quote on it we can talk about it his
name is paul farhey hold on james
o'keefe for people who didn't know yet
go ahead sorry about that my name is
james o'keefe his his first name is
paul's last name is f-a-r-h-i and i
believe it's far hip on twitter okay
he's a reporter at the washington post
and get this get this
just give me give me 30 seconds to
explain all right good um i said in the
first video on cnn quote and i said this
in my on camera introducing the segment
right i'd like to introduce you to cnn
supervising producer john bonnefeld in
atlanta the washington post reporter
wrote an article right after the video
came out that said and i quote
james doesn't include that he is based
in atlanta
what so
i wrote i wrote i said i'd like to
introduce you to cnn producer john
bonnefield atlanta and the washington
post wrote it doesn't disclose that he
is based in atlanta yeah you can't
possibly get you can't possibly get a
more clear
factual error than that so i emailed the
washington post i said please retract
yeah and they said to me and this is
their email printed out they said sorry
james editors have no correction
necessary i said i'm going to give you
one more chance they wrote sorry james
out of luck
wow
why is this so important well listen i
mean i this is kind of a minor deal but
the washington post is caught and i'm
and and i'm going to get a retraction so
i just figured i'd i'd get a retraction
so i could frame the retraction as yet
another example of fake news yes exactly
hey remember when fake news was a term
actually uh created by the left to
accuse all alternative right-wing media
of being that's why it was created that
didn't that didn't work out well for
them no it didn't really work out very
well worked out well though for uh for
facebook and the youtube trending feed
with seth meyers i remember seth meyers
he was like this is fake news all this
this right-wing media then he said it's
time to retire fake news no no no no no
no no no you don't get the we're gonna
appropriate that yes we are going to
appropriate okay this is important let
me show the audience people who haven't
seen it we have a couple of clips of
these videos that you've dropped and you
just dropped another one with zucker uh
naked jared here show the clip real
quick so people know how he's been
disrupting the world then why cnn
constantly like
rushed this rush of that
because his ratings yeah because it's
ratings our ratings are incredible right
now
but honestly you think the whole rusher
[ __ ] is just like [ __ ]
could be [ __ ] i mean it's mostly
[ __ ] right now
like we don't have any
big giant
proof what what do you think is going to
happen this week i mean with the whole
russia thing
thing is just a big nothing burger
really
you don't think that uh
there's nothing there you can do it
so uh okay first thing is everyone at
cnn gay
then
i probably shouldn't i probably
shouldn't get myself in trouble um um
but you've already showed up to the
program so it's beyond the realm of of
of saving
yes he does call it he says of the
journalism ethics he says that's
adorable that's adorable that and he
uses the adjective adorable described
people who would believe that cnn is
about
journalism he says that's an adorable
notion it's an absurd notion by the way
it says great ratings
very subjective term here really cnn
they've just been in the crapper for so
long and now media is fragmented fox
news has worse ratings than they did and
cnn's ratings are slightly better so
it's kind of done a little bit of this
but all of cable news is is going away
here within the next half a decade as
we've talked about as we know it anyway
so i know you just released your your
confrontation with zucker i know you
have another video coming out tomorrow
for people who don't know this is just
it's been blowing up everywhere
specifically the narrative of russia
right this is the thing seen and ran on
so for them to say there's nothing here
is is huge people may disagree with you
that is monumental especially after the
realm of the story that we knew was fake
like buzzfeed and uh what was it
buzzfeed and cnn the the peeing the
prostitute one yeah for everyone that
you know is untrue there's 20 more that
you don't necessarily hear about that's
right that's right and and that's
exactly right i mean this is uh the
analogy i use is we're taking the
beating heart of the mainstream boom
boom boom
and we're actually ripping it out of
their body this is an existential threat
what we're doing what what this this
whole american pravda a series is is a
threat to their monopoly on information
because they don't trust you with
information they want to shove
narratives down your throat and as you
said stephen if if if one of them is on
tape how many other people and by the
way let me just say this about john
bonafield in the first video i don't
think he's the villain i don't think
he's um a bad guy he seems like kind of
the way you or i would behave if we were
at the corporation i just think he's
sort of naked in his honesty and he's
just sort of telling the truth about the
culture of the company if anyone's the
villain it's the ceo yeah jeff zucker
who actually creates the company culture
that says stop doing investigative
reporting and start focusing on this
crap story that we know isn't true right
yeah and they've run with that for a
long time now to be fair this doesn't
mean that
nothing about russia is true it means
right now that the trump investigation
going after trump doesn't mean that
people like paul manafort there haven't
been some other ties what they try to do
is take some issues that are true entire
thread therefore trump colluded with
russia for the uh you know for for the
to win the election to steal the
election to use their term let me ask
you this obviously critics say you
edited this out of context uh why are
you just showing the montages why aren't
you releasing the full clips you know
i'd be remiss if i didn't ask that's
what you're critical of of course no no
i i'm happy that you did ask
there's so much to say but they use the
word selectively edited at this point
it's just become a joke i mean first of
all they say a lot of things about me i
mean i actually printed out for your
show a couple of these these bizarre
obfuscation i want to talk about
something the washington post wrote
about me he said and you know we're
we're reporters we're journalists we
present our material we
get in front of a camera and say okay
guys here's what happened and he goes
o'keefe and i'm going to quote this who
appears on the video as a kind of master
of ceremonies well what is that about i
mean every anchor and host read off
teleprompters i'm presenting the
material for an audience sure but i'm a
master of ceremony so they use a sort of
language like selectively edited all
journalism is edited in a selective
nature of course in fact most journalism
don't even show you their sources they
use anonymous sources so you can't even
see what the people are uh hold on i
have to call you on that that's not most
journalism that's just cnn
that's just the new york times and cnn
and washington post oh okay yeah and
huffington post uh this i it's always
funny i get you have to protect you
understand you have to protect your
sources we understand that sometimes
especially if it you know it's an issue
that would relate to someone's personal
security but you can't only use
anonymous sources for every bombshell
you have to use them occasionally
because every time you do so you rely
upon the reputation of your network
right so if all you're doing is just
drawing upon a credibility bank you're
not depositing any credibility into that
bank can you imagine if veritas oh well
hey steven i got a story yeah an
anonymous source told me that a bunch of
acorn employees told them that they were
starting brothels of child prostitution
and you'd say you're full of it o'keefe
i want to see the proof show me the
video tape we need to ask the new york
times and the washington post to show us
some not all
some of their sources yeah and that's
true and it does happen somewhat on the
right i think it's become the rule for
the left not the exception there are
some sets on the right where they do
that and it aggravates me as well like
listen you can't just only rely on
anonymous sources all the time um
listen we've always talked about this
we've broken some news which kind of in
it i mean you know we didn't expect to
get an interview with wendy davis
dressed up as a [ __ ] but it happened
so we have to run with it um but uh we
always as entertainers have tried to be
as transparent as possible while listing
our sources and actual urls as
entertainers just because we don't want
people to say that we're lying as
entertainers whereas sometimes jokes are
lies okay let me ask you this
you have another video at the time of
this show
can you tease first what is this going
to be is it going to be a bigger
bombshell lesser bombshell i think it's
you know everyone's different i think
it's probably stronger than the van
jones clip yeah it's similar to the
bonnefield clip but you know how we
don't go to different locations i'll say
this one's in new york this one's out of
the new york location where oh come on
there needs to be more than that well i
i i mean i scooped myself but um
we uh it's a it's a it's a
like it's hard for me to stupid gosh
it's someone in the new york location
who's describing the extreme bias
and some of the really bad elements of
their productions and how they're done i
think it's very strong i think listen
sure bonafield was a non-villain who is
telling the truth about the culture of
the company as directed by the ceo yeah
then jones is a star who is
contradicting himself public and private
in public he says russia's everything in
private he says it's a nothing burger
tomorrow you're going to see a different
element of the series two things first
off that could describe anybody in new
york so you didn't scoop anything on
yourself i could describe anyone in a
cnn at the turner broadcast building in
new york uh by the way actually we have
one of the senior editors from turner
who's a conservative who now works on
this show so there's some ladder with
crowder stickers hidden in the building
there maybe you'll find them next time
you go in um and by the way steven isn't
your in
isn't your audience bigger than cnn now
i mean don't you i mean i don't i don't
know what your numbers are but yeah yeah
overall 1 million 1.3 million viewers at
max i mean don't you have more reach
than they do yeah well we here's the
thing we have way more overall reach
it's hard to compare like for example we
went to advertisers if i don't have a
ton of time but this is actually
something when we went to advertisers
for sponsorships and we have a lot of
people come in and offer sponsorships
but i hate to say it's like we're not
we're not selling gold you know what i
mean like we don't want to do the self
lubricating pocket catheters we have a
much younger audience so we've been very
very selective and we have a few big
sponsorships we've been working with
who've really reached out to the show
well we didn't really know because we
haven't sold a ton of sponsorships we've
just you know run our own kind of ads
for mug club in our merch store um so we
went to someone who cuts all the the ad
sheets for like rush limbaugh and does a
lot of the buys and he explained to us
these numbers here are the rolling
quarterly average meaning
this amount of people could be tuning in
potentially every quarter hour so then
we gave him our numbers we don't release
our numbers publicly because we don't we
don't want to be the people who rest on
the laurels of our numbers hopefully the
content but i will say we're very
grateful and blessed to have a decent
audience when we said okay here are our
numbers and we said they don't seem as
as high as those but he said hold on a
second how long do they watch or listen
for well we said well over 40 minutes
and he came back at us with a rate sheet
that stunned us our mouth was a gap we
didn't know we had no idea that this is
what standard sponsorships went for
because the listen rate and the the
stay-through rate is so and it's even
lower on cable news and on am radio you
know howard stern stunned with 22
minutes so that's what's changing you
know let's say a quarter million people
are on one show online or a half a
million people it's the equivalent to
three four five times the amount of
people who incidentally flip through
cable news and that's a big thing with
you if you're getting a million people
watching one of these clips that's a
million people watching all the way
through not you know a million people
seeing 10 seconds of don lemon drunk off
his
the conversation we're having right now
is far more in-depth than anything you
never even see on television because
they do everything in like little
itty-bitty
fractural increments so there's that the
substantive part of it but you're all i
would i'm just going to make the
argument not knowing the analytics but
you guys and your audience are already
more powerful in my estimation than cnn
i mean your share talked about so i i
think it's no longer like david versus
people say oh you're going after goliath
in many ways i think like we are the
goliath yeah i still think though that
these networks have so much influence
over republicans and politicians and
they shame them and you know
it's not who's it's not how many people
but it's who is listening to them right
now that's it and unfortunately a lot of
not only liberals we expect them but i
said this when we went to youtube
youtube invited us out to this
conference at summit new york and uh i
never felt more alone not because of
google and the youtube people who we
knew were liberals but because of some
conservatives who were offended by us
remember i asked a question about the
women from buzzfeed painting with their
period blood and i spoke about it
bluntly and the guy behind was like well
i have a less salacious question i was
like well a second youtube featured this
so i'm going to throw we're going to do
bob ross painting muhammad in period
blood because we have to throw it back
at them so yeah it's not you expect it
from the left it's unfortunate when you
peel back the curtain and see it coming
from the right um i would certainly say
listen you have a bigger reach obviously
and much more impact than cena that's
why they're scared of you final question
before we go before all these videos
broke the night before three people uh
resigned at cnn three employees um was
that you when you were seeing that story
were you thinking they know
you know uh
i don't know if you're religious i think
you are a religious man i a lot of this
a lot of this is i i'm not kidding a lot
of this is just providential we got the
last
bit of footage on friday this
investigation took about
six months to do yeah people think oh
you just walked up to a guy no no no no
no
undercover work is extremely complex you
have to build relationships you have to
get them to draw them out we got the
last bit of footage friday in an
elevator friday night
and i was planning on doing other things
and then i saw that happen i pulled it
an all-nighter we put the material
together we changed our strategy and
sometimes these things just it's destiny
it's it's sometimes these things just
come together well there you go i will
say it's hard we have an undercover
video coming up not breaking news but we
went to uh where illegal immigrants um
get their you know they get picked up in
the back of the trucks and naked jared
and i went in there and actually offered
to do their jobs for slightly less and
uh hilarity ensues they were very
furious when by the way if you will
you'll be shocked at the amount these
people make the idea that these people
are taking jobs americans wouldn't do
for wages they wouldn't take it is far
greater than even the fight for 15
demands these people and it's tax-free
and not a big fan of white people coming
in just wanting to earn a living so it
doesn't take as long but it is still
really really hard and that's why i have
a tremendous amount of appreciation for
what you do where's the best place for
people to watch it as you uh drip drip
drop these james o'keefe i would just
say project veritas.com that's project
v-e-r-i-t-a-s dot com project very test
and of course tweet at
far hip yes please
please tweet it paul fari that's
f-a-r-h-i and ask him to retract the
article where he got a glaring factual
inaccuracy absolutely we'll do james
o'keefe thank you very much go do all
your other interviews we'll be back so
we're gone
see you later
can you count
monk lovers
i say the future
is ours
if you can count
now look
what we have before us
we have louder with crowding
right next to mark levin
on youtube we have not gay jerry
right next to stefan molyneux
on today's show alone you have james
o'keefe
right next to sargon of a car
and nobody
is trolling nobody
and that
is a miracle
[Music]
now there are a lot of people out there
who want to shut this club down but we
own these platforms with hundreds of
millions of plays and hundreds of
thousands of subscribers
and many more millions to come
there are over two dozen free
speech-centric channels here on youtube
millions of fans and supporters on
facebook and twitter alone
and there ain't but a few hundred damn
moderators in the whole place
can you dig it
can you dig it
can you
dig
[Applause]
is
[Music]
[Music]
all right we're back let's have our next
guest i'm gonna i'm gonna tell you this
i only think i've got one more segment
with this wig
i don't know i don't know how much
longer i can it is itchy and my i don't
know how i don't think it's this itchy
for women or they must be used to it uh
okay this next gentleman since it's like
we've said last show before we super
video but next week is our first week
off
in years so uh going out with a bang we
had james o'keefe and now we have this
man who's been in the news because of
vidcon and some some drama uh you know
his channel uh you know him sargon
sargon of akkad but some call him
carl how are you sir i'm very very well
you guys are gorgeous
you wear that so well well uh yes call
me jared yes
yes who are you wearing it is uh rape by
islamic migrant and uh it's available in
sweden swedish stores now it's available
in 62 no-go zones nhm yeah and nhm i
think it might be mandatory yes exactly
well that way it just so happens we're
so fortunate that uh not fortunate i
shouldn't use that word but we were
always planning on doing sweden as the
end of the month and they just upped the
no-go zones today with the police
commissioners saying we need help
there's going to be a civil war it's
already begun in some areas in sweden
like providential
yeah providential some would say i just
i i actually haven't been following
sweden i've been a bit busy recently yes
i know well stay away it's the muslim
it's the rape capital of the west so uh
speaking of rape and more of a
psychological sense you went to vidcon
and anita sarkeesian was there and this
is where all the drama kind of stems
from she's a feminist who she is
swindled people
she has she has you've called you've
called her out and uh you were at this
panel at vidcon it's a big conference
and she spotted you so we're gonna roll
the clip and we'll keep your mic on so
you can let people know who haven't seen
this most people have let's roll this
clip knock knock on my name on youtube
because she is like this dude
that's carlos
[Applause]
[Music]
endless videos that just go after every
feminist over and over and over again i
think is is a part of the issue of why
we have to have these conversations
and back with a hat i see what you did
there you couldn't get a screen print
sargon it wasn't given to me by a friend
actually at vidcon he brought it down
the next day so i guess he couldn't
that's like the kindergarten pace that
you use on youtube you're concerned that
your friend has t-shirt paint in his
knapsack
i was just uh pleased for the gift okay
so what's the fallout here she doesn't
like you you've criticized her
she's clearly very upset but since then
they've been investigating your patreon
i mean she's actually made it a mission
to really harm your ability to make a
living she absolutely has i mean it
doesn't matter that i support my family
with this patreon that's irrelevant to
anita what matters to anita is that she
punishes someone who disagrees with her
right and the thing is she'll she thinks
that i make videos on her on a regular
basis just go to my channel i i don't
think i've like debunked one of her
arguments since 2015
she's just not relevant and it's
i just
what would i say everything has already
been said about her nonsense arguments
they're wrong they're cherry-picked
they're misinterpreted they're heavily
biased or a feminist lens and so
literally everything is interpreted as
men oppressing women yeah it's just like
anita
you're just wrong
all the time and this is why nobody
defends your work i mean nobody if you
can find somebody who says i need
sarkeesians criticisms are great really
spot on on point right really stand by
them let me know you know i want to talk
to that person well because everything
you just said feminist things
everything you just said though could be
said about uh you or myself there are
people who make it a living to
say your crap or debunk your arguments
or my own or joe rogan has guys like
that but you have plenty of people on
the other side i mean the point is it
doesn't exclusively happen to women it
happens to anyone who creates content
obviously but the the problem is with
anita is that these criticisms are
consistently coming from both her
supporters and from her opponents right
i'm just saying she makes it sound like
it's only to feminine like it's only to
women and i'm saying it happens to you
to me to joe rogan to i mean there are
there are accounts created just for not
gay jared hate that's true there's a
whole minor community dedicating to
hating me it's really amusing actually
i have an anonymous username there i'm
not going to lie um
i just show up i'm like yeah and his
beard's really gay right guys
uh it is that means a lot from a guy in
a dress yes yes exactly who cannot grow
a beard uh by the way i probably i
probably look more like a swedish woman
than most swedish women today so
actually it's the arms that give it away
actually you've been working out man you
can tell no no no no no it's just uh
every man looks huge in a dress that's
the truth you take the small like jared
if you stan he would he looks massive
compared to woman it's just the bone
structure that's why i worry about
dinner most nights so what are you gonna
do here with anita sarkeesian um
patreon i mean she's shutting down
obviously youtube has been demonetizing
people so that's hard and patreon you've
relied on how do you how do you fight
back i mean this is a big deal well
luckily i didn't have to because patreon
aren't um idiots i guess they're not
crazy and they just look at my work and
say well what she's saying isn't true
okay and so they just rebutted them
within they were investigated by uh i
think contacted by things mike.com who
are big anita supporters yeah not really
of her work just ideologically yeah and
they were excited about the idea and
patreon said okay well yeah we're
looking into this and then two hours
later this email them saying you know he
hasn't done anything so everything anita
sarkeesian said is basically a lie and
that's confirmed by patreon so now is
she she's not suing you or anything is
she no a lot of people have said i
should sue her though for lying for for
yeah for liable well i was going to say
lawyer up if your your income has been
stopped because uh that's the only
language these people speak and it's one
let me ask this do you ever get tired of
it though a little bit because there's
obviously there's you know we do this
show and we don't have the time
necessarily to go back and forth with
everyone um i i know you've had a lot of
back and forth from some youtube it was
kind of like this drama in the community
do you ever just say like you just want
to move on is it does it get to be too
much because there's no winning at the
end of it
well i mean
when it comes to i really don't like
drama you know i'd literally i had
actually gone to that panel to actually
listen to what she had to say sure i
thought that she might have something
and we thought oh there'll be a question
and answer session this is our chance to
actually
address her with some of the criticisms
that we've had yeah
years ago you know i mean she's been
really irrelevant for a long time but i
thought this would be an interesting
thing you know maybe we can actually say
okay anita why did you ignore certain
aspects of games in order to sort of
formulate this fake criticism yeah stuff
like this you know
of course it didn't last uh the the
question announced the session was meant
to go on something like 15 20 minutes
and it was pulled after about three
questions yeah and there was a long
queue of people who still had questions
and they they just like shut it down i
will say some some of the questions are
more so like trolling statements than
questions and you know i've had people
show up where it's like yes question
yeah why do you suck so much you
right-wing nazi and i'm like well that's
not a question
come on and then i answer it anyway i
haven't said anything like that no
that's true you know the closest one was
uh the first chap who asked her directly
do you actually believe what you're
saying because and this is a question
that's dogged her for her entire career
because some of the things she says just
yeah i will say though i would be pissed
if someone asked me that because it's
just a way of trying to poke a hole into
your legitimacy now with her it may be
appropriate but it is the first thing a
lot of people say for example you're you
you have skepticism of uh you know the
uh the uh the paris accord you're just
paid by are you paid by big oil do you
believe this or oh that's a the thing is
you could just turn around and say well
of course i do i wouldn't put it on the
internet if i didn't yeah question
that's true
it's just done i mean if someone came up
to me and said hey do you actually
believe the things you say of course i
do you know but for some reason she
couldn't do that and i mean i i
genuinely believe she does believe the
crazy feminist things so i don't know
why she didn't i mean i i think she was
flustered in many other panels and stuff
like that and she is definitely a
feminist and she's quite a good one
actually she's just a really terrible
critic
yeah well i think you know this is what
we do with our show because we realize
like it'll be a full-time job in dealing
with youtube drama you know rebuttal
anyone can do rebuttals on youtube and
train you can have someone who is
functionally [ __ ] and they can make
a rebuttal look brilliant if you give
them enough time so we do if we put
something out and there's a legitimate
critique or there's something that we
think is really a problem we say okay uh
come on the show we'll talk about it and
if they don't come on live we move on
because you can't go back and forth with
video rebuttal at some point it's got to
occur live and if anita sarkeesian just
said okay you know what we'll do this
we'll actually have a one-on-one
conversation or debate and i know that
you're generally a very very civil guy
even in disagreements we've had uh then
it wouldn't be an issue but they when
you never do it that's where these
things grow it's like a cancer
and none you're absolutely right and
obviously she never does she never
addresses and she never has and she's
always been insulated by the sort of
class of the gaming press and the
progressive feminist activists that
surround her i mean it's almost like
they're complicit in all of this on
purpose you know they don't they don't
want to face any criticism and even when
they have criticisms of their own
they'll i mean if you're having a
one-on-one conversation with them or a
live stream with them they will say well
yeah i mean i have christians of her
work as well but then they will want to
talk about the harassment and it's like
okay well yeah i don't have anything to
do with harassment i just don't i don't
care go to the authorities go and report
i mean it's a crime yeah you know to
send some threat so just you know get
the fbi cyber division involved i don't
care well that's always why i say people
lawyer up for the same reason when
people go i get a thousand death threats
like no if people actually
we've actually worked with the fbi
because of the actual threats that we've
we've dealt with and so it's one thing
you go you talk about on social media
let your audience know and then take
actual action otherwise it's from like
okay sometimes you're just using this
for clicks or drama not you but i've
seen people do that yeah because real
threats you need to handle seriously
especially if you have a family which i
know you do um
we have sally cohn coming on after this
a great example someone i disagree with
vehemently but she always shows up and
we have a pretty civil discussion let me
ask you this i was just talking with
james o'keefe about this right before
you
it's not so much she has no audience but
it's the fact like you just mentioned uh
mentioned uh mike.com it's not that they
have an audience it's who they have at
their disposal wongkat mikes.com gawker
ms
there's this elitist i think there's
it's a good thing for us in the long run
because there's more of a disconnect but
they do have a lot of people in the
media who treat them as far more
legitimate than any audience ever does
oh yeah i mean i i spoke to a journalist
about this at vidcon and he suggested
that there may well be some sort of
click farming going out where
and this was his description of it to me
they
you get um clickbait websites they'll
have like you know 20
shark attacks or something yeah and then
you have a any individual individual
page for each picture that you're seeing
and so you have to click it 20 times and
so they count that as 20 different views
on these pages right and then apparently
they sell the views to places like
mike.com and i was just like i mean i'm
not i don't know if mike themselves do
that but it's a common industry practice
yes i was just like
i mean how can you sell a view on one
page to another it's insane well this
isn't new this is just new online but
you know no no that's actually what
happens with magazines when was the last
time you subscribed to a magazine
i don't think i ever have exactly i
subscribed once because a guy showed up
black at my house and said he'd been
shot five times this is how his you know
he had he had cleaned up his act he's
like now i sell magazine subscriptions
and i swear to you i bought a filmmaking
magazine
and reason magazine and i never got it
uh so i was hustled yeah i was hustled
but um this is true and greg gutfeld
talked about this because he was a head
editor at men's health and fhm i think
or maxim
magazines buy up subscriptions they buy
up each other's subscriptions they buy
up a bunch of subscriptions so they can
sell ad space most of the subscriptions
aren't real yeah and greg gutfeld who
worked in this industry talked about it
he's like no think about this if it
makes perfect sense gq magazine you will
read one article that just bashes
republicans and praises bernie tax the
rich and then the very next page is what
to wear to your yachting party no one's
going to read this you know yeah yeah
see i'm not part of the industry i'm
totally independent you know i just
started doing my youtube channel because
i wanted to talk about things and
suddenly i you know i'm talking to
people within the industry and so i'm
learning about all these practices and
thinking well no wonder i'm doing so
well you know no wonder you guys are
failing so badly yes you know yeah this
this shouldn't be happening but given
that you're so and i mean i would
i would consider that a real form of
dishonesty or corruption you know if you
if you're i mean click farming is just
like
you're not
you're not influencing people yeah
giving people the knowledge that the
information they need
and i wouldn't want to be in that
position because then you're just a
fraud well and then unfortunately we've
had people approach right-wing sites
who've approached us us about this like
you pay this amount and we just said
well we said no like well good luck and
they said we're going to steal your
content anyway and then just copy-pasted
our original columns and uh and didn't
even give a hat tip so that's kind of
you know they make you an offer you
can't refuse so there is fake news on
the right with that you know because we
posted right next to hillary clinton has
polio and aids and they're like hey
that's our op-ed right underneath it and
no credit to you know courtney or
whoever wrote it all right we do have to
get going we want to have you back on
for longer next time i know you're
making the rounds just like james
where's the best place for people to
support you right now amid the feminist
attack
uh just google sargon of akkad just all
this sargon and i'm the first thing that
comes up and you'll be able to find all
of my information that way probably my
docs as well this is true he's a cocky
english bastard just google sargon and
he will be there
google did it to me
stop it we have to go
i just read this here during the break
chair the daily show co-creator liz
winstead launches summer comedy tour for
reproductive rights
sounds like a barrel full of it wasn't
in the show map i'm just reading this
now so sorry if i missed that news from
earlier today hey thanks so much for
being with us thanks so much for
everybody thus far who has joined it
louder
crowder.com 99 annually 69 for students
club
with
not only do you get access to uh the
daily show but you get this wonderful
hand-etched hand-painted mug
and uh we yeah it's girthy and in a high
quality item you know we we give a lot
more content out on youtube than ever
before but like we said we're hoping to
be remonetized more monetized soon again
but we've seen a huge divot in there
just like you see with with sargon and
people we've talked with so uh mug club
is the ironically the only thing that
allows us to continue giving out free
content paying for that premium content
us doing the additional daily show and
what you see by the way you're not
seeing the lion's share we are doing a
full one hour show every day and of
course not gay jared courtney and gerald
have the friday morning show morning
grinders that's it louder with
crydor.com club 69 annually if you are a
student keeps everyone here employed
that's about a dozen people now on the
site and the show collectively you get
access to the whole crtv lineup and you
know it's actually what allows us for
the first time to go on vacation because
we were always scrambling just for the
well hold on you know what maybe i
shouldn't say that because then people
are not going that's true because they
don't they love us so much they love us
we give you it's like the prestige we
are giving you pieces of ourselves in
little boxes every day can we just get
one day to ourselves
one day
lottowski.com
let's go
[Music]
all right glad to be with you so we were
talking about this right during the
break here and uh you can follow her
she's one of my favorite guests because
she always comes she's happy she's a
kind person i know people why would you
no listen i would say it a lot of people
who come on the shows are are our
horrible people uh she's not one of them
at sally cohen sally thank you for being
with us
hey uh nice to see you inga yes is that
uh so you actually we should have we
should have named ourselves not gay we
should have no we didn't have official
names uh we caught we caught everything
else about swedish this is ahmed i mean
you know that i'm not uh
there was a slow reveal when we were
talking initially because i i saw the
dress i liked the dress i liked the wig
not so much the part behind you know i
actually just came i was just in sweden
uh
as as a uh you know american white
lesbian woman
yeah managed to not get attacked wow
i'm genuinely glad for you weak i mean i
just but you know you keep you keep
pushing those stereotypes man that's
good for you no i'm really i'm really
i'm really and you keep pushing that
anecdotal evidence i'm genuinely happy
for you because i would not want
anything bad to happen anecdotal
evidence no it's not they just made the
they just added eight new no-go zones to
sweden today
all right to 61 no-go zones i mean
that's crazy can you read no-go zones in
your country but here this is the point
you're talking about often we'll go back
to that all right all right because i
don't want you to think where i don't
want to no no
but you were talking about the you you
know you didn't you didn't like this and
i and i can understand it's not it's not
for everybody um but you were talking
about about jokes and about comedy and
and your view on it you think that i
only like comedy if it's offensive um
no well go ahead you go ahead and
represent my views and then i'll okay
now go ahead go ahead you said you said
you seem you said you seem to like jokes
that are that offends somebody as you
say i feel like you
well uh i was phrasing it in the in the
inverse so in other words i okay believe
it or not would go out of my way not to
offend people right and i feel like you
i think you have a great sense of humor
you know i think this stephen but i feel
like you um
like uh a joke gets a bonus for you if
it offends people you you like that part
well i can't say that that's wrong if it
offends the right people so in this case
if it offends terrorists in sweden
creating no-go zones i can sleep with
myself at night um i do think people say
this it's and this is something that i
do think the left sometimes misses
they don't realize that they do say
things that are far more hateful than a
joke that's offensive you know whether
it's saying like republicans want to
kill poor people with their health care
bill there's both sides have rhetoric
and they don't realize you're insulting
somebody it's true correct yeah so i uh
but that being said if you tune in to
trevor noah you tune in to any of these
folks samantha b just talked about paul
ryan masturbating to the thought of
people losing health care i think uh a
blow-up terrorist doll is far less
offensive
um okay so meanwhile i just wanna cause
when you ever hear about these no-go
zones uh and you know this is a very
interesting this this choose your own
facts situation but uh so i'm not gonna
cite the new york times god forbid
and like credible journalists but i'm
gonna go with snopes yeah uh snopes is
full of crap
i'm gonna go with the came out before
when they said no no go zones and they
were in france and the the you know the
the mayor of paris and the prime
minister france came out and said
nope that's not true that doesn't exist
well i'm i'm looking for credible news
okay uh go directly
this is directly
the swedish police commissioner
okay so i would say he's more legitimate
than snopes he said he said listen and
we have it i mean i don't i don't uh we
have it from earlier today we never have
like sources already i think jared might
have the source do you have it we have
it from earlier today i don't know if
it's the actual swedish website it is
which we had to translate yeah we can
bring it up i see it cited on breitbart
i'm looking for no no on the swedish
website listen i will go independently
research it on my own i'm not uh yeah so
this and this has been going on for a
long we've been following it for a long
time um and uh and yeah it is it is true
he even said there's there's irreparable
damage to the fabric here as far as we
need to get not talking about a race
issue but talking about we need to
stay with the foundation he actually
says here on the swedish radio website
the police do not use the term no go
zones so i mean
it's not it says it's uh did you just
translate the swedish website we put up
particularly vulnerable no it's it's in
english sweet is this from snopes
you know
it would be nice if we like trafficked
in fact and
sally sally here's the thing
sally this is what's not this is what's
let me finish
this isn't right for you today when you
say that when you say let's uh deal with
facts when you say things or left to say
things i i think i've seen you say
things like this you can correct me
wrong that uh republicans don't care
about the poor losing health insurance
when you say we just said that isn't a
front that's deliberately designed to be
offensive to people you disagree with
you're just offended your offense tends
to be different it's a blow up doll with
a beard that's uh that is a valid
critique i i did you just kiss him no no
i just pointed to him because he can't
see him that well unless i do this okay
cool and the problem is the chair it
moves with me i'm fine with that so i
can't i can't there you go uh
and he's happy he's having a good time
listen hey that's the point and i have
to say no no this this is listen i mean
you know fair point right we all have a
profoundly we have become so polarized
that what's
truly like um
philosophically and morally interesting
to me is that we all seem to seem to
agree on the
inapprop like where the lines are of
inappropriateness we just disagree about
who's on which side
of those lines and that does that does
that does worry me so uh i mean you know
we could talk about that more but i i
don't think there is a line in humor the
america i would say this the only thing
that i would say with humor um that
really gets people mad is if you
relentlessly attack the defenseless so
you know like really attack uh i know
people get really up in arms if it's a
politician's child who didn't enter into
the fray i don't do that or if you're
really attacking someone specifically
who's mentally uh disabled but outside
of that i don't really believe that
there is a line in comedy i just believe
that there's a line for each person what
you like and what you don't like um but
uh i well i mean look there's no line
when it comes to free speech right i
think we can both agree on that well i'm
actually glad to hear you say that yeah
tenants should be able to say whatever
you want to say thank you
and free speech includes your right to
be able to say it and my right to be
able to be offended yes uh my right to
protest it your right to protest me
protesting you like we didn't go on like
this for years um
uh you know i
i do think though it's interesting i'm
not sure i would exempt comedy in the
way you do because i think
um
i don't know i think
maybe putting putting that piece aside
we all should have sort of reasonable
standards of humanity and decency and
what does worry me and i'm again i'm not
exempting this i'm not saying i've
always been
perfect uh ever
in the last three days like you know
sure uh yes but is that we should all
uh aspire to
have our disagreements and our and our
debates sure without it devolving into
something that actually undermines the
sort of
common humanity that i i hope we all
hold and continue to remember i think i
think we do that on the show i mean
we've had you i know you don't like the
the gag here today but we've had you on
a lot and i feel like we're pretty fair
and give you a platform to speak
certainly more so than cnn
man yes we and by the way everyone
should be uh even if you disagree kinda
at sally cohen uh
uh as a matter of fact uh we've we've
had remarkably good uh results with
having people with differing opinions
you always get some people had lots of
persians lib turd um we got a lot of got
really heated we had uh convert crowder
day we had a man come on who uh tried to
convert me to catholicism i'm i'm not a
catholic but it was very respectful and
that gets in you know people can get
really mad when you get into theology
um okay i was going to convert you to
lesbianism when i saw the dress yes
well i think i'm pretty much already
there
yeah um no no uh i mean first of all
i love being on cnn cnn is good to me
let's not i caught that slip but uh but
second listen wait are you now are you
at cnn and you're p yeah i still am and
your people uh by the way are absolutely
delightful i wouldn't come uh i wouldn't
come back on if i didn't think your
audience was uh you know always
open-minded i honestly thought i thought
for here's the thing this is not a lie i
don't have cable i thought for some
reason you were with msnbc so you know
this is funny so do apparently a lot of
the media outlets i keep getting called
okay okay so then it's not just that's
probably how i found out same time this
week i think it was town hall this week
called me a uh liberal msnbc anchor so
not only a different network but i got a
promotion i'm not correcting them yes
that's okay yes
yeah she's she is a liberal msnbc anchor
also she has 21 kills in the war on
terror okay i'm not going to correct you
she rides around with a harley just
covered in skulls
like that yes where's that stake well
okay so you aren't cnn hey can i go back
before i forget happy birthday thank you
very much i appreciate that yeah thank
you for reminding me that age is
inevitable
i am a little disturbed that you're um
20 years younger than i am uh
but uh i thought we were sort of
contemporaries it's fine we are pretty
much contemporaries i mean but we're
both youngins i won't make those 30
under 30 lists anymore i won't make
those 30 most influential 30 lists which
by the way croc
croc total croc um okay well here you
talked about cnn so you talk about
dealing in facts uh
listen snopes is incorrect and i'll tell
you snopes has been factually incorrect
on claims that we've made
okay openly especially with cologne
germany
so um because we do listen even we've
talked about this even though we do a
lot of comedy in the show if we do make
claims
we do actually try to source well we
always put the source up and we do
actually try to base those claims in
some kind of reality we've seen from
politifact and snopes they've been less
than honest sometimes so speaking of
this right now you're talking about cnn
right now obviously they're in a lot of
hot water people are talking about you
know the term fake news was created by
the left to kind of toss at the right
now it's been turned around and now fake
news uh they're using a lot against the
left it's being tossed at cnn a whole
lot what is it like working at cnn cnn
right now is it is it chaotic
no
um no it's uh
as sound and reputable as ever look at
that
i'm not gonna i don't know i'm not i'm
gonna disagree with you i'm not to
elaine too much what sorry i said i'm
not going to go i'm not going to go with
you there's i i mean listen we know
there's a bias at cnn everyone knows
that
i just wish they were honest about it
i mean
okay
can we let's do this i i i'm happy to
have a conversation with you about uh
bias reality of bias perception of bias
why is it whenever i'm one with you do
you have a landline
i thought you said we were
contemporaries
do you have the keypad that's like the
size 24 font
services i don't know
literally only when i'm talking to you
uh
a landline yeah anyway that's zucker
saying don't go there don't go there
they want a donation yes undoubtedly um
all right so i'm happy to have a
conversation with you i i i'm gonna stay
out of the fray i'm not gonna sort of
you know okay i understand because you
work there i don't want to put you in
with respect to cnn obviously right um
you know listen
i i have to say i've actually sort of
having done this for a while last of you
i've been stunned and this was true when
i was at fox news as well by the way
yeah of how people in the media's
viewpoints are actually generally more
in the middle than
uh either perspective in the country and
that and that's very interesting for a
whole host of reasons and as a community
organizer i find that problematic right
that oh that word media represents so
much of the middle
um
but they really do and when you talk
behind the scenes to a lot of the
anchors who you maybe think of as
liberal and biased they actually are
pretty middle of the road and you talk
to a lot of the fox news people you may
think is pretty conservative and right
they actually are more middle of the
road and i i you know so there's that
piece the other piece is look
reporters are reporters journalists are
journalists and this whole fake news
attack
uh by trump
look when the stories were wrong the
outlets said they were wrong and in
every other instance which by the way is
the most of them
they were accurate in fact incorrect
well i mean so tell me tell me where
that's all fits okay we got the false
comey report in june uh i'm turning this
off the top of my head we have the false
report from buzzfeed and sorry cnn about
the pissing prostitutes on furniture um
we have the fake trump dossier which
jake tapper helped push what else uh it
was a recent one obviously there's a
libel that you can't that cnn has to
face because of the reason so out of
like hundreds and hundreds and hundreds
no no
they've spent hundreds and hundreds of
hours on this no but but let me give an
example i was on a conservative radio
show and and i mentioned that trump had
leaked intelligence information to
the russian ambassador and the host went
after me just went out oh that's fake
news and you're citing new york times in
washington post and i said well it was
the exact same day the exact same day
that trump himself
in a conversation with netanyahu
admitted that he had done just that so
but trump at the time
before when the story came out he
attacked it as fake news fake news has
become a euphemism for news i don't like
that's and it was created by the left
for everyone who was on the right snopes
did it with us politifact did it with us
and now we've jiu-jitsu and the shoe is
on the other foot
we could be talking about facts i just
think well i just did talk about facts
i'll just give you a list of examples so
here's let's let's go to facts in that
statement that you just made so you just
said he admitted to benjamin netanyahu
what did donald trump admit
he admitted that he gave intelligence to
the russian ambassador and said he
didn't name israel as the source of the
intelligence okay okay so this is this
is the one story that we're talking
about we go back
right but that was after he had said
that reporting that he did that was fake
news now well it's not well hold on a
second because there was there was fake
news and naming is in naming israel
there was here's and this here's the
problem with the left like we just
talked about with california they'll
take something to hold on
reported let me finish they'll take
something true for example if you guys
said okay there's some unsavory
characters in his cabinet in this
administration the paul manafort thing
boom direct russia ties okay fine but
instead you say donald trump is under
investigation donald trump himself has
ties to russia there's no evidence of it
and they run for hours on it
hours
again this is interesting because i feel
like all i see is the media and these
outlets and and really
good journalists who are breaking their
backs to get these stories in an
environment of increasing uh you know
closing off access to the press
being so careful to not say
that they that he is suspected of direct
uh direct collusion i haven't never seen
the times the washington post cnn ever
say that they they have said that there
is an investigation
with respect to whether there was on the
part of some of his campaign advisors
but like no no no no no no no and that's
and that's what the james james o'keefe
thinks recently people have been you
know that's that's the issue people have
with people saying listen we know
there's nothing here right now and they
keep pushing if you'd have gone with
okay like you said that that common
thread of truth that's fine but people
right now and this is the thing right
now they're hearing this and they're
going hold on a second i feel like every
damn day there's a new trump russia bomb
bombshell because there is and they all
end up going away because they come from
unnamed unsourced uh sources we see that
all the time unnamed sources right now
from cnn unnamed sources from new york
times he just said the new york times
said that the no-go zones didn't
increase in sweden the police
commissioner said that's not true i
didn't say that i just said they could i
couldn't find a couldn't find a source
so let's
number two uh see but there you go
that's what you see what i mean like it
becomes i said i didn't say that um
what was the new york times that you
just read about on sweden and rape
because that was important that was that
was one i was reading a sweden i was
reading a swedish radio uh no no before
that you were reading new york times
there wasn't one i couldn't find one no
i said what i said was i couldn't find a
source i couldn't find a link okay
before that you read new york times
thing i i was i can't remember what it
was it was something to do with sweden
before the swedish thing you read
something from new york times i believe
you but i don't remember um i don't
think it's uh
go ahead let's replay the tape i think
it was snopes uh okay
republicans control congress both houses
both houses are investigating
not only whether there was
any
collusion of which there is currently no
consequential proof let's be clear
but also the fact that our our
hard-working intelligence agencies have
definitively said russia tried to
interfere in our election even that even
that president trump still says is fake
news okay
you're blaming the media no no no here's
the thing if you just said that if you
just said that if you just said that
you wouldn't have the left wouldn't have
lost so much credibility you don't need
the recent false russia gate report you
don't need the false comey report you
don't need to fake russia dossier from
jake tapper that's why cnn's facing 100
million dollar libel suit and that's why
they'll likely get dinged on it if you
just said what you just said that
there's an investigation into the
administration regarding ties to russia
no one would care but they've come down
with such defe and all of these stories
coming from unnamed sources cnn with
buzzfeed pissing prostitutes you
remember fake doctors remember when
donald trump said that it was because of
an unnamed source that he could prove
that barack obama wasn't president
and that was moronic but he's not it is
a reputable news source
but fake news and attacks on the
president and oh poor donald trump's
being attacked no i didn't say any of
that held accountable no he's not
there's never seen that in the lie a
good
if you're going to hold me accountable
for everything the left does i get to
hold you accountable for everything i'm
not holding you accountable you said you
said the net left news cnn that they
were reputable news sources and i'm
saying that they are not and then i said
i'm only going to speak for myself okay
okay well that's right you did say the
media in general i'm saying the reason
the americans distrust again let's let's
kind of fill in blind spots the reason
that conservatives in the united states
don't trust the media is because of fake
dossiers fake stories from unnamed
sources good example we just had james
o'keefe on the show i know you probably
don't like him but he released his video
and we he just showed us right now the
document where he talked about the man
uh
director the first person in atlanta
georgia the washington post released an
article saying he fails to mention that
this man was actually based in atlanta
georgia he sent them an email saying
this is actually the original release
will you issue a retraction they said no
washington post people want to tell us
they're reputable they're not
there's a reason people don't trust them
anymore
that's all i i don't okay
you have a you have trump
who
has
documented lie after lie after lie after
lie not mistakes not reports that were
inaccurate and retracted not slips of
the tongue not error we're talking
deliberate
conscientious repeated lies
but we're going to push all that to the
side
we're talking we're talking lots and
lots and lots we're going to put all
that to the side no and cherry pick i
think what he got five six
stories
that and even we could peel off i'm
going off if you want me to if you want
me to pull up my show maps i can i could
give you more than you have in a
lifetime just take what it's more than
six i could give you at least right now
i can give you at least two three dozen
um i just gave you six off the top of my
head here's the thing i understand what
you're saying
now i am not in the business of a truth
here's the thing the main reason that
this matters the main delineating
factors is the left defends it as
reputable news they created the term
fake news donald trump here's the deal
you might be right
but
you're attributing motive there he might
there might be some slips of the tongue
there's certainly been instances where
he's been woefully incorrect and
misleading and i talked about how i feel
bad for his team when he sends them out
there and they contradict each other and
the misinformation
i am not putting all of that aside but
that doesn't make it okay for mainstream
news networks to simply be misleading
and create and run with false stories
without any substantiation and that's
why we have a problem trusting them and
i i i would really wish people got on
them more than me for the the
ventriloquist dummy back here with the
beard
i okay so here's where we maybe can
agree i do hold mainstream media to a
higher standard than you stephen thank
you very much that's all i ask uh number
one
uh the difference is the president when
confronted
with
examples of his lies his misstatements
maybe they were slips to the tongue
maybe with their accents let's be
generous i'm willing to do that okay
they were accidents
confronted he then repeats them
he has no
interest
in representing the truth the media
outlets i will say and again we could
get into the weeds on each story
when they make a mistake
they correct it there's accountability
no they fix the story they fix this and
that's the main issue that's the that's
the main issues where we disagree i i
agree with you don't need to put either
to the side neither is acceptable but
the media doesn't and they haven't just
now we have the ability to call them on
it someone with a cell phone video
camera someone who can do a little bit
of digging online can say oh
that's untrue and here's videographic
evidence and they don't like it so i
wish that they kept themselves
accountable i really do but i don't
think they do and i hate that people
like me have to
i don't think this is
but we do have to get going so let you
wrap it up matter of fact this is about
sorry what do you want to say i said we
do have to get going so i want to i'll
let you wrap it up
oh no as i said look
it's just stunning to me that like a
couple of edited videotapes by you know
a known misleading huckster like james
o'keefe uh you know they serve your
ideological agenda so you're gonna
believe those we've got
dozens and dozens of unedited dashboard
cams that clearly show a pattern but you
know
part of the country doesn't like the
conclusions that don't i don't know i
don't think i don't think you watched
art i don't think you watched our set no
no i think i think that we've been
remarkably consistent hands up don't
shoot was a lie philando castile was a
screw-up when we talked about that in
the show and so we wish the cop had
better training this was a screw-up we
think that this is sad this is not just
you're talking there's a pattern you're
talking two videos show a pattern in the
media well no i don't think there's no
pattern
i don't think i don't think james
o'keefe has been misleading perhaps i
don't think james o'keefe has been
misleading i think just saying it's
selectively edited that's what everyone
said with andrew breitbart until all of
a sudden he was the one who got anthony
weiner to resign they all said he lies
nothing's true and then damn anthony
weiner came out and they said okay
andrew was right about that but he's
still probably wrong on everything else
i don't think it's just leading
and i think you're on facts to fit your
just like there are no more no-go zones
at sally cohn but i do love you man i do
love you as well thank you very much for
people who are listening we'll be back
to wrap this all up in a bow that is
nicer than this
[Music]
[Applause]
hey there handsome
no not not you oh
lord no i'm talking about that snazzy
t-shirt looks like someone's been
dropping some coin at loudou with
crowdershop.com
now come near let the world see don't be
shy
there we go that's what i'm talking
about
oh now
someone's trying to be a sneaky fellow
let's go we're that bad boy loud and
proud nothing to be ashamed of here
say what's the big idea stop kidding
around and show everybody your swag
don't make me come down there
i will come down there
well now your t-shirt just says
socialism which is far more embarrassing
there we go see nothing to be afraid of
available exclusively at
louderwithcrowdershop.com mug clubbers
are almost never beaten up for wearing a
long-sleeve socialism is for [ __ ]
t-shirt unless of course you're sickly
looking and lacking self-confidence and
that's why we now sell long-sleeve
versions perfect for those cool summer
nights and covering up a lifetime of gym
avoidance and poor decisions get yours
now at
louderwithcrowdershop.com that's lotto
with crowdershop.com
because anywhere else would be pure
faculty
[Music]
all right we are back
did i
did i did we jerry-rig a string up so
that we could just
yes we did yes we did
you're welcome
said the ladder with crowder gang why am
i seeing you on my monitor i want to see
your stupid little punim uh thank you to
sally cohen thanks sargon of cad james
o'keefe sally cone i know people are
going to get mad this is one thing
that's a real problem uh on social media
or even on twitter if we post a story
that people need to know
or if we have someone on who they
disagree with
people will not hit the like button or
hit the share button even if they
actually think they've learned something
or they've enjoyed the segment people
say i won't hit like because i don't
like sally cohn and that is something
that is a real problem now where people
just i only hit like to things i agree
with oh yeah already i only thumbs up
things as a matter of fact we'll have
videos on topics where we are actually
rebutting the topics or topics that we
seriously disagree with and we'll notice
a huge amount of down votes because
people see a title on it a title on a
topic that they don't like i don't
i don't like that yes we didn't rape no
one does we're trying to inform you yes
no one does it we are trying to inform
you uh with the information i don't know
what sally comes up with the no goes
this is the issue with the left tooth
the minutia of we're gonna say no go
zone it's not a no-go zone it's just a
place where you shouldn't go if you
don't want to get raped like okay all
right i'll give that one to you let's
just say please don't go there if you
don't want a a staggeringly increased
chance of getting raped zone
it's just harder to say honestly it's
like bogo isn't really buy one get one
free it's usually like buy one get one
half off which is incredibly misleading
but it is a catchy phrase i didn't even
know that about bogo i thought bogo
always meant buy one get one free no
it's a rip off
pay less slide pay less slide yeah you
don't even shop at payless
pay
even less
shoe outlet
and you go there it's just like it's co
dot co dot co dot uk
dot us by the way anytime you see a lot
of dots and a title is probably fake
news uh next week we are going to be
dark as far as the daily show we have a
huge video coming up with the illegal
immigration that should be good and uh
the following week we've already booked
it up with some fantastic guests and we
have some
pretty big jihadi bond and uh maybe some
trying to ban uh segments in the works
so um listen
we have to go pretty soon here we've
done three guests let me just be
brutally honest with you okay
this week uh i i'm i didn't want to be
here right now i'm tired uh and i'm i'm
fed up with a lot of a lot of things
particularly the news it's been a long
time since i've taken time off the last
couple weeks have been have been pretty
pretty tiring we've been traveling we
did ireland we did new york and there
have just been some issues so i'm not
going to lie to you there are some times
where i have i'm just like ugh i don't
want to be i don't want to be doing this
right now last weekend i was so tired i
was like in a physical like i couldn't
move borderline coma
uh and i think i've talked about this
where i have um fibromyalgia and
sometimes i'll just get everything will
get really sore so that was a component
to and i get really tired but i did not
want to get up and for the first time in
months
this last weekend i slept past uh nine
o'clock
and i realized so i kind of have a rule
in the morning when i get up uh before
before work is i don't do any writing on
my phone
in bed period i don't check news in bed
so in other words if i want to get the
day started if i want to work i have to
get out of bed so and i also don't want
to wake up my wife that's the process so
that could be anywhere from five o'clock
six o'clock in the morning i'm up and
then i go have my my morning beverage
which
starts my body moving mm-hmm and uh read
the news and start getting started on
the website a lot of credit.com and then
we come in we do the pitch meeting so
there's kind of an order to the day but
i was so tired and i didn't have to work
on saturday that's kind of my day off
that i woke up at seven went back to
sleep and then it was about 9 30. and i
stayed in bed
probably until about 11 30. my wife was
gone by the way i should say so i didn't
have a whole lot to do
and i felt like crap for the whole day i
was like oh my whole day my rhythm was
screwed up i didn't end up going to the
gym i just i just felt like crap and i
realized it's because i thought well uh
today is now so i just was scanning
things on my phone i didn't want to get
up i was tired and i realized that
that's just a huge portion of of doing
anything
in life uh is getting up that's just a
daily it's not even an issue because you
set it you set that timer you set a rule
i'm not doing this from bed i have to
get up a huge component to getting
anything done to making any progress in
your life people have talked about i
mean we were talking about my friend
chill son and you know he had he had a
child
he lost from from listeria
um we had him on the show he just won a
fight recently and him and his wife were
talking about that and they said you
know how do you deal with something like
that and they just you just get up so
it's kind of
and she said it's it's how you deal with
anything it starts by just getting up
starts by getting up the next day and
then the next day and once you get up
you do something else you you set some
goal for yourself i think there's a
misconception a lot of people say this i
was talking actually with uh i fell in
love with sound guy edward while we were
taping this video about this there's
this mis
conceived notion that successful people
not saying we're successful i mean come
on this is moderate in the most generous
of terms uh but that successful people
just
they just meant you can do anything you
put your mind to and so that means they
just they will it into existence no
you don't you don't just put your mind
to being lebron james you don't just put
your mind to creating a new app or
software that changes the world that's
that's there's this idea it's better in
a bumper sticker anything you put your
mind to no you put your mind to for
example um okay i want to play in the
nba you put your mind to first if you
can't put your mind at being six seven
but i digress you put your mind to okay
who's the best person who can coach me
you put your mind to what's the best
process to learn you put your mind to
how do i need a train to get stronger
how do i need a train to get faster who
are the best possible training partners
i can have you put your mind to which
school do i need to go to you put your
mind to what kind of grades do i need to
get you put your mind to what kind of
letters do i need to send out to get
scouts to come and see me you put your
mind to where should i be where's the
right city what's the best environment
what kind of influences do i need to
eliminate from my life you put your mind
to all of it and all of that starts with
just putting your mind to getting up and
i realized the whole weekend i didn't
feel good all of that yeah it was
exacerbated but i felt like crap because
it started with me on a saturday just
not getting up usually i don't have a
choice
but i just i didn't that sunday i got up
early the next day i had nothing to do
so you know again i digress the next
sunday kind of sucked i was up early for
no apparent reason i need to split the
difference but you put your mind to all
those things there isn't just willing it
and saying oh man you can do whatever
you put your mind to just dream aim for
the a is it aim for the moon or you land
on the stars which is totally inaccurate
it should be moon is closer than the
stars that's not what it is it's not a
bumper sticker it's putting your mind to
each and every individual action that
will lead you to accomplishing your goal
successful people are able to accomplish
set reasonable goals and expectations
and exceed them consistently and it
starts with you'd be amazed just not
hitting that snooze button getting up
set it before you do something tomorrow
i often get emails about that saying hey
you know which i'm in college and i'm
depressed because everyone's liberal it
starts with getting up
and i mean that both literally and
figuratively i mean it literally it
starts with getting up early in the
morning and figuratively if you have a
problem if you you feel as though you're
an outsider at your school if you're
backsliding and whatever it is your your
sport your athletic endeavors your faith
your relationships
you just gotta get up you gotta find at
some point all right i'm not gonna let
that happen
i'm getting up i'm getting out of bed
and i'm doing something that is the
defining difference i know for me and
whether i have a good day or a bad day
often a good week or a bad week and uh i
know i look back on my life
that's often what it's been with any any
scenario any area of my life where i
feel uh somewhat completed somewhat
satisfied hope it helps you if it
doesn't then there is no pleasing you
next week we're dark i'm not here
it only takes some time
[Music]